this is a production of cornell
university
yep everybody's in um so for our live
audience uh welcome to the
fourth episode this year the cornell
turf show fastest 30 minutes in turf
uh happy again to have rich buckley
director of the plant diagnostic lab at
rutgers rich was on with us yesterday
for episode three uh our golf
golf audience uh have you chat with rich
today about early season diseases on
on lawn areas and some common problems
we might notice
so for our live audience fill out that
poll there we'll close that a little bit
um but as always we'll start with frank
um beautiful sunny morning in most of
the northeast frank where
things are kind of looking up and as
always you start us off on a little bit
of a light note
usually um got anything uh interesting
fun from social media for
uh well um uh honestly carl
uh i'm i'm all business today uh
unfortunately
and and part of it is because it's it's
still damn cold i was out there doing
chores this morning
uh and it was uh in the 20s everything's
frozen
um and so it's been a interesting start
to the year
and i just assume get into the weather
but i'm sort of wondering
uh what we're seeing in the poll already
this morning do we know where everyone's
from
yeah so i'll just close it up here and
it looks like about a third of a third
of the audience
school grounds and fields some educators
in there 22 percent
uh one person from a municipality and
then a couple others in there so
probably a combination of those three
all right well um
you know this is the we're doing lawn uh
and grounds
um uh every other week with sports
um and golf happens every week because
you know those guys are nutty
and they want to hear from us every week
and and you know it's a
incredibly intensive management system
and and
of course sports is as well and certain
lawns can be and certainly if you're in
the
institutional grounds business like our
brother here at cornell
dan scheid uh you know all about when
you have to do things uh at a fairly
large scale as you do in the background
here at the greenwood cemetery
um so listen let's talk about the winter
you know i get to chat about the weather
with a lot of different people and
present the weather
in a lot of different ways and sometimes
and it gets curated over a period of
time
as you wrap up and get into the growing
season and
and this has certainly been a warmer
than normal winter now again
i think carl we asked folks this last
week and a lot of people said
they thought it felt cool or maybe they
felt it felt normal
but this was uh slightly above average
uh when can
when looking at the entire uh course of
the winter now
what's interesting is um we're already
uh starting to see some drought we went
into
uh the winter with a bit of drought and
it looks like we're already
uh coming out in some places
particularly here
along us you know southern new england
the coast of new england we have a lot
of contact with our colleague victoria
wallace at the university of connecticut
who talks a lot about how dry it's been
out there for a number of years now
southeastern new england
has really hit it on the chin had it on
the chin the last
several years with regard to uh drought
now
the interesting thing about the winter
uh when you look at a national
perspective and again i talked about
this with the golf folks last week a
little bit
um you know we had a lot of snow across
the entire united states lots of concern
about
places where we're trying to grow warm
season grasses in these regions
of the central united states but but up
here we had a lot of
persistent snow cover but when you
actually look at the moisture
and you know this is the funny thing you
sort of know where you are
if you look where i live we live here
carl in in central new york
uh you know it's a fairly it was a
fairly wet
winter on the whole certainly slightly
above average
rich has been wet now for several years
i think rich is starting to believe he
lives in a rain forest or something but
there's certainly
we're plenty of wet areas down here in
jersey and
and throughout the northeast again
fairly dry
it was a fairly dry winter even in even
in new england
and and in western new york especially
up along the lake in rochester
so uh what's coming well looks like a
swat the moisture's coming through
uh this is not good in some ways for
uh any place that's gonna get a lot of
traffic uh
even trying to get work done when the
soil is wet
from the rainfall that's expected and i
just love that
this is two inch rainfall plus right
where rich is so we'll have plenty of
time to talk about
what the cool wet weather is going to
bring so uh degree days
uh so far as we accumulate them this is
a good
tracking for insects and weeds we use
phenology a lot we'll talk a little bit
more about phenology phenological
indicators
when plants are blooming and when things
like pests can coincide
with the plant bloom um obviously we do
that for forsythia bloom and
crabgrass stuff and insect stuff so uh
as you can see not a lot of uh base 50
growing degree days we're
still down uh fairly low and not many
expected now
the 8 to 14 day forecast for much of the
northeast
uh is above normal i'll show you a map
in a minute that says we're expected to
have above normal temperatures next week
but
at least from a degree day perspective
above 50 degree day perspective
we do not expect to accumulate a lot
next next week now
just to remind everybody about you know
again out mowing
and doing stuff you know i know we're
pent up to want to get out there
but growth potential even when you know
we're barely making average temperatures
of 50 degrees
that means the greatest a grass could
possibly grow is 20
of of full potential so obviously you
know
we want to be careful now some of this
is because
of the fall spring or is the full spring
in some cases
i don't know how many people knew this i
should have brought this up with art the
other day but
new york actually has 12 seasons that
includes this full spring
and you can see this is what happened in
early march
uh just last week where we had 60 degree
temperatures
and we still are you know i was out
today it was in the teens
and so when you look at the national
phenology network that looks at
flowering plants
this is the spring leaf index sort of
how trees and plants
are leafing out like the dark red is
where you're about 20 days ahead
plus or minus and the blue zone is where
you're about 20 days behind
now up until just a few days ago we
hadn't really
leafed out very much at all so we want
to be careful
not to jump the gun here again much like
what we talked to you guys about
last year now as the snow melts one of
the things you're likely to see this
year
because of the widespread snow issues
were problems with voles
so this is a fill the soil and get some
seed on there
um you know this is they're not like
moles it's a little bit different
i mean you can do trapping but it and
they're not going back to feed there
anymore they're going to find the
alternative food sources that are a
little more protected
they were out there of course underneath
the snow well insulated and protected
and that's why you're seeing
some of this so fairly easy problem to
solve so since we're starting to look
down below the soil
let's look at two inch soil temperatures
this morning um
or on the 18th and and it looks like
we're just
creeping into the low 40s uh in southern
new jersey
you can see where the heat is building
to the south but still barely cracking
the 50 degree mark so again
just to remind everybody how early we
are now
one of the things that's fascinating
about being able to
look at data that google can accumulate
is the ability to look at google trends
and one of the
search terms i have found to be
interesting to teach a lot about how
people pay attention to the soil
is put in soil in to the google trends
search document and you'll get uh the
ability to look at how much
people searched for the term soil since
2004
on google and what you notice is this
very
interesting heartbeat of interest
in the spring uh in the in the northern
hemisphere
uh for the word soil look at what
happened last year
in the pandemic we're expecting a
similar interest in this
going forward we're going to talk more
about soil stuff as we keep going during
the year but it's very interesting that
how many people will actually google
something with the word
soil in it right at this time of year
now the other thing they should have
been googling is what do i do with dead
grass along the sidewalk right
we know this has to do likely with soil
uh grass
the soil warming right next to the
pavement
grass breaking dormancy late snowfalls
that require
salt applications and then widespread
death
right along the edge of the sidewalk
there and so obviously
replanting these areas is a priority in
many grounds
facilities you know generally it
requires a little bit of
of stirring up the soil obviously these
are soil problems as well as
plant problems so trying to fix the soil
there this is not an easy problem to fix
and honestly what our research would
tell you is
the later the snowfall the more you
should consider
alternative de-icing salts that
are more expensive but less injurious to
the grass so
one of the ways to prevent this from
happening is to try to obviously not
drive the tractors and things on the
sidewalks
but also switch to a salt that might
have
less damagement problems to a grass
stand
than otherwise uh the rock salt that we
typically use
now got a question uh from
county extension office down in
westchester county our new
extension person down there hillary uh
taking over for the retired jerry
giordano for those who didn't know that
and the question was from a local person
about
uh picking the right grass seed and what
does cornell have for resources on this
well if you go to the cornell turf grass
website you will see
a turfgrass species and variety guide
we did it as an ibook many years ago my
long time colleague mary thurn
did this as an ibook many years ago and
while the variety
information in there would be dated it's
about six years old
the process of selecting and the
information in there is still
really very good and very easy to access
from a pdf perspective now if you look
at we have simple
charts in there like you know if you
have more full sun
uh and and higher visual quality you
want obviously maybe more kentucky
bluegrass and perennial ryegrass
you can still have tall fescue in there
but you know tall fescue moves you into
more mowing
it also does better with no irrigation
so there's a good narrative here
and a really good table summarizing
all the good uh varieties available and
i'll joke with i'll i'll joke with rich
before we get on there because
you know one of our goals rich with you
is to sell some rucker seed right
brother
yes indeed all right now so before we
get to talking about rutgers seed
uh for those of you that might be
thinking oh i got to get my pre-crab out
oh i got to get my weed and feed out
because you think you might be seeing
crab grass
let me just remind you that this this
data pull
from the gdd tracker that's maintained
at michigan state university
that's uh timing of uh crab grass
germination which you know
into the soils get into the 50s we're
not even talking about this
and you can see crabgrass is just
beginning to germinate
uh just in north florida all the way up
into
the low country along the coast of uh
south carolina
right so we got a waze yet now why is
that important
well it's important because if you put
your pre-emergent herbicide down
now it's gonna start to break down
right and if you if you get 12 weeks out
of it you know do the math
you still uh are going to have seedlings
emerging
after the herbicides broken down and
here's just
emergence data from ontario canada
of crabgrassing along and even though
these are degree days and days of the
year you can see
calendar days right so this is well into
the summer
june early july right you're still
getting 20 30 percent of the crab grass
is still going to germinate
right and if if your pre-emergence
product wears out
you know now you're going to have more
problems with crabgrass later on so
we're early yet
don't go crazy so since we got rich here
uh
and what the kinds of things we're going
to see certainly one of the things
i've noticed uh you know out at the barn
at the farm rich is where i got a shaded
barn
i got a pretty good crop of grey snow
mold so you'll definitely see
likely snow mold and shaded low wet
areas
but the one thing i actually wanted to
chat with you about
because it's been bugging me for a while
uh
is this idea of red thread rich um
i i want to pivot to you here and talk a
little bit about
um red thread issues that
as well as pink snow molding lawns is
going to start coming on
and what we've noticed about more red
thread
over the last several years so why don't
we start with chatting about
uh red thread what are your thoughts
about where we're at
you know in the 25 20 some odd years you
and i have been chatting about this
well red thread of course we always kind
of consider
it one of the first diseases you're
going to see because it's got a low
temperature through
it it'll grow from 30 degrees to 85
degrees
so pretty much uh any time of year even
now
yeah you know you you'll see you'll see
red threat if you walk across a ryegrass
uh uh past year you'll find some you
know and and uh
it's a it's a disease that uh you know
it's not real virulence
it's not like gray leaf spot it's not
going to kill everything but but it's
going to
it's going to flare generally in
under managed turf grass areas you know
lower input leaner fertility wise
and and i mean that's the conventional
wisdom well that that then i'm gonna
stop you
because that's what i was taught by noel
jackson in rhode island
and now i'm seeing rough i'm seeing
high-end lawns with
it i'm seeing it in in um you know rough
areas on golf courses for sure
but in places that i wouldn't say
are necessarily low fertility uh
and i wouldn't say are necessarily
places where we see it a lot our are
and i think over the last few years this
has been one of those lawn diseases that
the conditions maybe have persisted
longer
for it in the spring and i think it's
starting to take out some turf
well i i think i think that you're right
about the conditions
you know we have these longer warmer
seasons with more moisture
um you know clearly it's been raining
like like crazy here
um but you know the temperature comes up
and
you get 50 degrees and it stays that way
and you know from
from first to april until the first of
june
with regular rainfall and you're in the
window where the where the pathogen
likes to grow
um you know we always talk to eric
nelson used to talk about moisture as
the on and off switch
and temperature as the throttle you know
and and
where if we get the temperature within
the range that the
fungus grows the fastest you're going to
get more damage
you know regardless of of management
practice
and and you're going to get a a
longer period of damage which will
expose crowns to traffic and
and so you may see dead or thinning
grass
you know it's a cumulative effect but uh
uh
for sure it's not you know i read noel
jackson's book too you know
and and i used to have
professor joe peterson he used to always
tell me fungi don't read the book
and so so so yeah i think i think you'll
see it in higher
higher higher end lawn areas now in
general
in general much like we would with the
snow molds
uh particularly gray snow mold uh where
you might see a
greater preponderance of it particularly
in low wet areas shaded areas
you know once we get to active growth
rich don't
how do you i mean you're not liking
treating for these things in lawns
you're liking uh rake it up get some
seed in there
let's get let's get some active growth
uh let's get some conditions for growth
you're not
recommending any fungicides for any of
these molds or
uh red threads early in the season on on
lawns
or maybe on high end estate grounds or
maybe front you know fronts of buildings
anywhere you'd recommend an early season
fungicide i i don't i you know
once the snow melts the grace almost
done yeah right and and so
generally that that's a pathogen that's
going to blight leaves and
the crowns are going to survive and you
know raking it up
and uh maybe a little end to push it
push it into growth once we get into
that growth potential
um you know it'll disappear like it
wasn't even there uh in most
most landscape turf i'm not that
concerned about it i mean clearly
down in westchester you know in
scarsdale there's
people that have to have perfection you
know but uh
most of us don't need perfection and if
you don't need it
you know we're seeing that some you know
we're seeing some winter damage too
you know and and and i got i got some
direct uh
twitter messages today of lawns with
pink snow mold
which i almost never see now paint pink
pink is
is you know in a home lawn
i i it's got a worse prognosis you know
you're going to see some death
but i still think you know seeding and
and just recovering that way as opposed
to a fungicide just wake up
and pink snow mold certainly is going to
go it's going to go sniffing out the rye
grass pretty quickly right i mean if the
any rye grass and power you have in
there is going to get
uh found by the pink snowmobile wouldn't
you think that's where it's going to
start
yeah that's right and it's more
susceptible and uh
and that's a mobile fungus you know it
makes the bazillion spores and it moves
around
and so it's gonna it's gonna move and
it's gonna
and it'll stay active you know uh uh
yesterday you know we had 24 hours of
rainfall
you know and it was 45 degrees perfect
conditions for it
you know so if i'm a golf course
superintendent i might have saw that
coming and
made a fungicide application you know
all my putting greens
but in the home lawn you know most
people don't notice
and uh it is what it is it'll continue
to flare up
under those conditions and and so what
about another foliar problem
uh leaf spot before we go underground i
want to talk about roots we're going to
talk about aeration and some
some lawn root challenges but let's
start with leaf spot
leaf spot is one of those things that
again once the temperatures start
getting above 50 if we stay wet
particularly you guys you know you're
going to continue to see leaf spots
or if we really outgrown leaf spot as a
problem because most of our varieties
now are resistant to it
well that's a great question uh you know
the fungus makes spores now
you know when it and you're going to see
it uh
reproducing on thatch you know into
april
before it starts to get into the leaves
and starting to cause spots
um most of the newer varieties have some
degree of resistance in them i mean
they've been breeding for leaf spot
resistance since like 1965
yeah and as long as we've been alive you
know and so so but i still i still get
uh
sod growers who are growing tall fescue
sod and blending a little kentucky
bluegrass in
and going with cheap old varieties and
so we
most of the time i get it from those
guys or inside
recently installed song you know so
it's still it's still out there it's not
as big a concern
as it used to be put it that way all
right good so
so we always want to make sure we plug a
little bit of record see while we're
here while we got you
uh and certainly there's a lot of
seeding going on
at this time and and again this is a
time to get some seed down to out
compete the weeds
and at the same time if you see a
certain
if you have chronic problems
particularly with diseases rich
i mean we have so many better varieties
than we just did even five to seven
years ago
um obviously you you want to believe
continuing to introduce new genetics in
any thinning areas is the key
uh i'm all off that's 100 correct
and if i if you talk to bill meyer dr
meyer will say that the best varieties
this year
are way down the list in five years
takes about five years
to improve and and it's been ongoing
since the 1950s in ryegrass
and we have some really good new
scientists uh
uh uh working in the tall fescues so
for ryegrasses and tall fescues where
we're we're running way ahead of
of the path and you know spend a little
bit more money for
for a newer improved variety and you get
what you pay for
well and furthermore uh you know the
wind out of the west with the seed cup
industry is is that rye grass production
is going to be down
rye grass seeds going up which uh you
know you visit the guys who oversee
the golf courses in the desert and then
they all start getting nervous
with the amount of seed those people buy
a little bit of a price increase is
going to hit everybody but
listen rich let's get to the soil
because um
obviously a lot of bluegrass a lot of
annual bluegrass gets into lawns
um if the soils are tight these kinds of
lawns can be
prone to summer patch they might be
prone to
fairy ring uh historically you know on
the golf course we had this conversation
the other day about it
uh with regard to get it and getting it
down getting it in
uh let's start first with uh how often
do you see
uh significant summer patch problems on
lawns
and when you do what what do you think
it's about
we well we we see a fair amount of
summer patching lawns
you know uh uh the lawn and landscape
professionals that that use our
laboratory
are generally working in higher end
properties you know northwest jersey
is one of the richest places in the
country so so there's a lot of really
high-end bluegrass
and so we get summer patch in there and
uh
uh you know in those situations
you know we try to work with them on an
integrated program of cultural
adjustments you know uh soil ph
matters a lot uh with the with summer
patch
i mean you want to get down to about
five and a half um compacted soils
uh matter a lot even in in moderately or
low
compaction sites air core verification
uh improves the the situation
uh you know as long as you're doing it
at the right time a year you know uh
there's some contradiction in the
verification
but i think it was basically because the
trials were done late
you know guys are air fighting if you
air fry early and
you can recover some roots and some
growth it's a benefit
um we also uh uh think about how to cut
you know we want we want you up two and
a half inches three inches
rather than if you get if you're below
two inches it increases the disease
you know so so if you you know and then
lastly
there are varieties that tolerate it
better
so if you've got to have bluegrass you
can overseed some of those thin spots
and and you know and and no no
no homeowner can tell the difference
between bluegrass and rye grass with
tall fescue
and so if you can get the same leaf
you know and the same kind of color just
oversee it in rye grass
you know problem solved yeah yeah that's
exactly right it's so interesting uh to
hear you say that because
there are so many bluegrass varieties
it's harder to change things in the blue
grasses but i always like
the integrated approach number one if
you're having chronic problems
it's got to be related to something in
your soil this is
these root pathogens are definitely soil
related so
obviously getting after those problems
now that said
i think there's a broader conversation
to be had about
do we need to airfy lawns that don't
have problems
uh you know what do we need because
first off
when you're air finding a lawn it's not
like they're finding a putting green
where you're getting it on one inch
you know three quarter inch tines on
half inch spacings rich where you turn
the damn thing into swiss cheese
you see the average you know grounds or
lawn aerator
uh it's making a hole every four inches
and then lucky you get down
two inches you know maybe it depends how
wet it is
you're being kind right but i'm thinking
about
even if you got the jet you know the the
the jackrabbit that's driving it in
vertically which is the one you know we
like
um you're still not making a lot of
holes and i'm wondering
you know is there you know is there
value in this or is it just something
we've concocted
to be able to sell a service uh
and you know i often think we're also
burping the soil
so you know gases are going off you're
burning an engine
you know you're making it look like
something if you don't need to
i think it's important that there are
things that are indicators
of this weed growth summer patch
uh i don't know fairy ring where do you
put lawn fairy ring in this discussion
some people get those issues yeah i i
mean
for fair ring the the you know and well
the first the greater point is
i agree there's no reason in the law in
a landscape to
core um if you don't need to if you're
not trying to fix something
you know and and lo and largely because
um the the the technique is poor
you know the equipment is not the same
you know we have to fill the holes with
sand or compost or something to make it
long-term and most most people can't
afford or
aren't willing to go there you know and
and so
uh uh so so but if you have summer patch
or compaction or lots of thatch maybe
that's a
place that you you know if you can do it
right um with fairy rings
the biggest issue is the soil becoming
hydrophobic
and and if if you have them and you need
to do something about it because you're
losing grass
you need decor and core very
aggressively
and then maybe use wedding agents to try
you know and which wedding agents i
don't
really see used in lawn and landscape
it's something that that maybe could be
adopted you know and digging the soil
out's not a solution either right
no oh you see great pictures i got great
pictures of of
guys who dug out the fairy ring and then
it's like two feet away the
next year it's back and they dug it out
again and it's two feet away it's back
that's just you know you're just perfect
people digging digging holes it reminds
me of uh the conversation in nick
menchik and the
soil sifters from across the street carl
we're close to the witching hour we got
any questions
yeah we got one question from sean uh he
was asking
you know it sounds like what we're
talking today you know rich you're maybe
more concerned about pink snowmobile he
was thinking
uh you know the opposite that usually we
consider gray snow mold to be more
deadly than think snow mold
is that because uh rich you were kind of
saying pink snowmobile just has a longer
period of time it can grow and reproduce
in the spring yeah yeah well pink
snowball has a lot
wider uh temperature range where it's
going to grow right so
you you you'll see it um in uh uh
in in late may even in shady spots and
and and so that's something um you know
the other thing too in lone landscape
it's it's usually gray you know it's not
usually pink it's kind of unusual to see
and and so uh maybe that's why you know
you got a lot of snow cover and
and you got some gray snow mold and a
lot of and a lot of winter kill too
and and it's and it the impression is
that it's worse
um but it's less it's a less virulent
path you know
and but once the snow goes away uh
it the the gray snowmobile doesn't keep
growing that's the problem with pink
snowmobile the damn thing just keeps
if it's raining in 45 degrees it'll just
keep growing and growing and growing and
and worse yet if you go mowing and
raking things along it you're gonna
start streaking it
uh all over the lawn is all over the
lawn as well yeah yeah
carl another question uh yeah dave
chinnery was asking if people should dig
out their soil for summer patch it
sounds like
that's probably not that's probably not
a technique we should do for anything
no we just we want to get along we just
want to get along with summer patch you
know it's ghosted
all right hey rich thanks a lot for
taking the time
really appreciate you doing two days in
a row and we'll probably be talking to
you next thursday for the
conference call that we'll start doing
uh amongst our uh
thursday morning gang carl take us out
of here yep
uh again uh for rich buckley frank rossi
uh thanks guys for joining
us today um you know fourth fourth
episode
cornell turf show uh fastest 30 minutes
in turf in the books
uh thanks all to the live audience we'll
see you guys next week
same time same place thanks a lot guys
see you thank you guys
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu